hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments [ __ ] dude hey Mark who's your
first subscriber mine is my cousin one
more thing have fun on the tour in the
Hoosier State well that just goes to
show how long it's been since the last
reading your comments didn't mean to do
that but the tour got in the way my
first subscriber was actually my friend
Michele who did it Morris like a show of
faith as a friend then firm belief that
I would go on to accomplish things in
YouTube but it still meant a lot to me
and along with that came some family
members some other friends but the first
one who is definitely my friend Michelle
and I I owe a lot to that first show of
faith and then eventually my videos got
kind of posted on Reddit and elsewhere
and then I got a lot more attention from
that and then I started building from
there but you know that was the first
subscriber and you know it's really
meaningful just to get that that one
subscriber you may not even know who
they are but you know that one it's the
start of something special so it's kind
of cool who comes up with the titles for
your videos I do I don't know what kind
of mad genius can possibly come up with
such illustrious and amazing titles such
as this and whoa and wow that's a good
one coming up with the title is hard you
can't go to clickbait t unless you
really want to or you can't go to boring
and generic so you kind of have to find
this weird middle ground and oftentimes
a title will be something that makes me
laugh but has nothing to do with the
video so it's a fine line to walk and
there's no signs to it have you ever
been blackmailed at any time of your
life and if yes how did you deal with it
serious question well serious answer no
I've never been blackmailed I don't
think being blackmailed is that common
of a thing or maybe it is if you guys
out there have been blackmailed in your
life write down in the comments below
because I don't know it seems like such
a cloak-and-dagger style thing you get
like a brick with a letter attached to a
crash through your window and you have
to unwrap
Linton's cut Magazine papers and they've
got a tape of you banging a coconut or
something and you just have to be like
oh god I don't want that video of me
[ __ ] that coconut to get out well no
that wasn't an example by the way that's
never happened to me it it's I've never
never banged the coconut mark what's the
highest you can scream I'm genuinely
curious well the best thing for you to
do on the first video where you record
in the day without any warm-up is scream
as high as you can here we go okay
that's about as good as I that's about
as good as that's gonna get all my
neighbors are gonna be very pissed and
every dog in a ten-mile radius is now
dead just four goofs chica is alive and
well
look at this bump who is a bump who's
your papa
oh it's the bubbies she's so confused
try not to cry challenge please under it
I don't know why why does everyone want
me to cry so badly oh man all I need to
do to cry is watch some of you guys's
thank-you videos or congratulations
videos or anything like that like
nothing gets me tearing up faster than
any of those so maybe I'll do some maybe
a reaction video they want you are you a
potato God I might be a potato but
dynamic new claims to being a god but
sir you are amazing I am aware but as a
potato you need to have
dad mark are you actually voicing 505 on
villainess I've heard this going around
but don't know if it's actually true it
is 100% true I am the voice of 500 5 on
villainous if you don't know what that
is it's this lovable character right
here this adorable bear which is
basically just all the voicing done for
505 is in so yeah if you want check out
villainous upload a link through the
description below it's a Mexican
animation studio one of their first
things going up on Cartoon Network they
did it as an experiment and it really
picked up a lot of traction really
quickly so I'm actually pretty proud to
be a part of it and I hope it goes on to
do great things in the future and if
they want me to keep doing 505 I'm more
than happy to contribute my voice what
do you think of bacon okay
I've said this before I'm actually
eating a very specific diet called the
keto diet and it's not really all that
complicated all it amounts to is eating
a ton of fat no carbs and some protein
so when it comes to bacon bacon has
become the staple of my entire diet I
pretty much eat bacon for breakfast
lunch and dinner so yes this would just
make our brother move faster I don't
think I can't those tiny arms I just I
can't deal with it I'm sorry what's your
favorite year and why are you talking
about any year from the beginning of
recorded history to now I'm just gonna
go of the years that I've been doing
YouTube I think 2014 was probably my
favorite year just because 2014 was when
I first moved to LA and it was this
beginning of this engine of creation
that I started doing and I threw out a
lot of really weird and interesting
concepts they're like the impossible
let's play that one five nights at
Freddy's first came about
that's when I started doing the vlogs on
the regular that's when I started doing
these weird unboxing videos that I kinda
want to bring back it wasn't really
unboxing videos but it was just I would
go and I would get [ __ ] toys and
then I would play with them while I was
doing a vlog and I tried a lot of
different things like that and I kind of
liked the concept of them so they've
been evolving and bleeding into my
videos ever since and I hope to someday
refine them down into something that I
can actually call real yeah maybe if I
saw mark and chica at the park I would
probably go pet chica first well to be
perfectly honest I would do the same but
also you're implying that after you're
done petting chica you're gonna start
petting me as well I don't know if I'm
okay with that I usually like meeting
fans in the street but if you start
petting me I'm not I don't think I'm
okay with that don't pet me if you pet
me
I'm gonna bite ya I will literally take
a chunk out of your hand
you come you pet me I bite you hey Mark
can you share a bartending story I'm
interested in becoming a bartender and
curious as to some stories about
bartending okay so for those of you
don't know I was a bartender for about a
month a little less than a month if you
can't EXO days that I was working pretty
much not very much and I wasn't very
experienced so here's my embarrassing
bartending story about my first day on
the job I actually knew the drinks
pretty well and I knew all the house
drinks very well but it was my first
drink that I had ever served and I froze
up because the guy asked for of vodka
cranberry and that's not a complicated
order that's about as basic as an order
can get in any aspect in any scenario a
vodka cranberry it's it's a highball
glass ice vodka cranberry juice that's
it but I panicked because I'd been
studying up all these complicated drinks
of various names I had all booked that I
was like memorizing to the T I memorized
every single of our 20 house drinks to
the
letter and I practiced them all but when
it came to my first order being a vodka
cranberry I completely froze up I looked
this guy in the I'm like you you want
that I grabbed a shaker I filled it with
ice I just filled the [ __ ] shaker
with ice took vodka and I just dumped
that [ __ ] in like I was totally blanking
I was like looking to my fellow
bartender for help I was like I don't
that's enough I guess and I grabbed the
cranberry juice I was like I'm pretty
sure this is how this goes but I think
I'm doing something wrong the guy at the
bar is is looking at me like who came
yeah thank you no I can order something
else you give me a beer and I'm like no
I got this I got it put the lid on shook
it up real good like for way too long I
was just shaking and shaking and shaking
someone Photoshop a dykon-- in my hand
here who's just shaken up and then I
just it was obviously way too much so I
had a highball glass out there I took
that off I took like a beer mug just
poured the whole [ __ ] thing into a
beer mug you know normally if you over
serve someone it's like they're grateful
this guy was so confused and my only
saving grace is that this event only
happened between this guy and myself
nothing no one else seemed to notice it
no one noticed it as soon as he paid he
literally grabbed the mug and walked
away began and this is not a bar where
you can take the drinks with you he just
[ __ ] walked away whatever it costs to
not deal with you Markie knew I was
wondering about how you overcame any
self doubts about pursuing your YouTube
career if you do see or read this know
that you bring me so much joy every day
when I click the play button I'm never
disappointed when watching a markiplier
video thank you well thank you very much
that's high praise to give me and I'm
pretty sure there's been some
disappointing videos in the past but
when it comes to your question about how
I overcame any self doubts about
pursuing a YouTube career
it's it's a bit of a it's a bit of a
chicken before the egg kind of question
to ask yourself because you can't have
any self doubts if you haven't already
imposed a limit on yourself and the
thing about a YouTube career is that
when I was pursuing it it was not going
to be my career it's definitely not on
the table and you should never approach
it as that you shouldn't go into YouTube
being like this is the only thing I'm
gonna do in my life and if I fail I am
going to die because that is going to
[ __ ] you and that cripples everybody
that goes into something with that kind
of energy when you go into it it's not
that you don't have limitations it's
that if you impose caps on your skill
you don't realize the potential you have
to learn and so when I went into it
there was of course better youtubers and
I was out at the time there were people
with millions of subscribers there were
people who with all sorts of levels of
success but when when I end when I went
into it I realized that I had so much to
learn and instead of allowing that to be
a daunting fact I just took that into
myself and I realized I have every day
to try to learn a new thing I have every
day to try to learn more about this
craft and make it into something great
without worrying about making money or
making it my career or making it the
thing that I was gonna do all my life
because YouTube in and of itself is only
a means by which to create and creation
is the thing that is fulfilling your
life it doesn't define it it fulfills
your life the ability to channel your
creativity into something tangible like
a video but also that translates to
anything else that you would create so
it when it comes to overcoming self
doubts there are no self doubts because
I don't know what I can do I will only
know what I can't do
when I push myself through what I can so
I didn't have any doubts I had none and
it was because there were no doubts time
the tour is over
where to pole dancing vid well it would
be there but the person that I wanted to
do it with hasn't gotten back to me yet
so I may just have to buy my own pole
and then figure that [ __ ] out on my own
so we will see about that mark don't run
into a tree
[Music]